[Music]
we live at a time when google's android
operating system has reached every
corner of the globe
according to statista.com and
mashable.com android has reached 80 of
the worldwide smartphone market
businesses have been employing experts
with certified experience in android app
development considerably quicker than
professionals with certified knowledge
in any other mobile technology
so what's better than starting your
career in android development since its
inception the android studio has been an
industry staple in developing
applications for android devices
this column course on the introduction
to android studio has been created in
collaboration with prominent youtube
channel codes easy which helped create
the lessons along with simplylearn
the course consists of an introduction
to android studio platform and a
thorough rundown of its interface it
concludes with developing a wallpaper
application from scratch
there are no pre-requirements for the
course however basic understanding of
programming is beneficial this gallup
initiative by simply learn allows you to
take the lessons at your own pace
completely free of cost
all you have to do is sign up on the
introduction to android studio course
page on our website and you can start
your journey in android development
because android has a lucrative revenue
model several companies have set up
specialized teams for android
development and recruiting is gaining
pace learning app development has the
unique advantage of allowing students to
work or freelance
similarly once someone has mastered
building apps for android developing
apps for any other operating system
becomes a breeze so get ahead to our
website and register for the skill of
course or introduction to android studio
today get certified by simply learn and
boost your resume
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here